there's a word I've been hearing a lot
the last couple days you may have heard
it too called comprar Matt yeah it's the
Russian word for compromising material
it's been in the news and apparently
it's standard practice in Russia to
gather information for blackmail
purposes and then they supposedly have a
lot of compromise on Donald Trump that's
what they're saying well fortunately for
us a man who actually worked in the
Kremlin's compromised
recently defected no one else has talked
to him we got a hold of him
pretend come on
it's raining out you want to be outside
then get on board with the premise yeah
knock it off anyway please welcome from
an undisclosed location he ran the
comprar Matt Cole organization in
Eastern Europe Nikolay Oransky let's get
him in here
good evening good evening Nikolay
welcome I can now use a good connection
not coming please don't use my real name
use my new American name Doug sander
does Sanders all right well Doug now I
understand your Bureau collected
information on a large number of public
figures is that right yes it's true you
never know you may need to manipulate
you know presidents Pope's wait you have
a file on the Pope let's just say that
yes okay
all right so I can throw a few famous
figures at you and you tell me what the
Russians have found on them far away you
know I can say that no in Russia you
can't say that all right yeah yeah we
got it yeah we literally be killed
that's the joke yeah yeah yeah well how
about someone like Mike Pence what do
you got on here Mike Pence yes we have
Whittle of him flying to Philippines to
bet on illegal cockfight okay all right
how about Hillary Clinton we love her
without pantsuit
and you can clearly see most of her body
is robot apart okay big jumble all right
how about don't do that how about how
about Melania Trump what do you have on
her well we stole her diary she wrote
that when she has six with Donald Trump
she imagines she is lying in the field
eating strawberries with Aragorn from
Lord of the Rings delicately he places
each strawberry in her pouty mouth she
reaches and gently unbuckles his
codpiece he says no I can't I am engaged
to elf lady she says I am your elf lady
now he says okay cool let's do this
then he unsheathed his man's sword and
he gets on top
we got it we got it that's plenty yeah
good god you know that word for word
what about what about Paul Ryan with you
of him masturbating in the hotel okay
Ted Cruz masturbating in hotel Mitch
McConnell masturbating in the hotel look
owner
we have almost everybody masturbating in
the hotel and once we get Ruth Bader
Ginsburg we'll have the whole Supreme
Court all forgot not paying for at
living here hey aren't you worried
Vladimir Putin will seek revenge now
that you're out here making all of
Russia's comprar mats public oh no no
not at all Putin loves me in fact he
just moved me into this new luxury
office complex and paid for whole thing
so I don't think that there's any chance
of hotel Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
well I was killed in Maggie
Wow congratulations thank you so much I
didn't think anyone could survive what
just happened you know what I didn't
know what to do when the clip ran so I
forgot to move Russian defector Nikolai
RN ski thank you
you